I said this was what we call a Radian
measure result right so at last I'm
going to have a starting point that is
not some random thing like a look at
this inequality why is it true I don't
know this is something this is where
textbooks begin because you guys know
Radian measure you know results for
geometry that kind of thing so I'm
interested in three particular shapes
here okay number one I'm interested in
this triangle or a big triangle
away--but
okay then I'm interested in sector or AV
so the slice of pizza and then lastly
I'm interested in the bigger triangle
here trying to oh hey tee okay I'll call
the tee because I've got a tangent going
through here and believe it or not this
is where actually you're like sine sames
means curvy cosine that means complement
of curves being ten wide it contain
tangent was that the new tangents this
is what I salute engines okay so watch
it'll come out this triangle here is
formed off that station from this
readers okay there's my radius R yeah
all right now remember I told you I'm
interested in all of these two shapes
okay so can we work out each of their
areas that's what I'm after so I've got
an angle in here X and as before I'm
considering it just as an acute angle
okay so 0 less than X less than Y on to
okay there's my domain so can we work
out with these areas on let's try the
first one the area triangle OAB
well I've got two side legs and I've got
an angle so which way should I get it
area half a me side scene right which in
this case a and B are both the radii and
include an angle I'm after is the X so a
half a B becomes half R squared and sine
C becomes silent top okay no no after
the area of this sector Oh Amy okay and
again this is just a standard Radian
measure and result right area of a
sector is ah a square feet up which in
this case is just X all right now lastly
this is a little extra work but not that
much what's the area of this bigger
triangle area of triangle or towel
what's its area well here it's not quite
so simple I need to know well I've got
one side length ah I also know that this
is a right angle T on there okay so what
should I do I probably need like you
know base and height right because I've
already got height here that's just the
perpendicular height so how I work out
this base yeah 18 how'd you go bathroom
this actually is a little bit like when
I asked you to prove sign the
expansion's for sign a plus B and cause
a plus B and I said find the links of
these sides in terms of trigonometric
functions right now think about this
I've got this side ah I noted this angle
X and I'm trying to work out 18 the
ratio I'm after that relates this side
of this side of that angle is opposite
mana Jason just ten so therefore
10 X is equal to opposite on adjacent 80
on our okay so therefore the actual
length I'm after is our Tenex happy ok
so I've got that distance yeah now the
area of a triangle is 1/2 base times
height
there's my base there's my height so the
area is thanks I've got my on two at the
time okay all right now can you see why
I brought up this result okay and think
about in connection for what I'm trying
to prove have a look at these three
shapes number one the small triangle
number two the sector number three this
are bigger file their forms on the pager
no matter where you move the team okay
suppose I move it let's let's draw
another circle and here I've got the
same time I'm going to move the team we
used to be able to he's on the move
close up something like there okay and
then I draw that tangent draw that there
you go there's another version of this
but it's smaller there's three shapes
one two three will always be this is
always more than that this is always
more than that right so I'll write that
as of area of OAB is always less than
the sector that's surrounded and the
area of this sector is always smaller
than the area of the triangle formed
around it by the tangent which is
triangular
okay suppose chances you already knew
that year 11 students who've returned a
with with a permission dearth you can
get her and there's a list here people
who have it ah this is tricky because
there are two of you and it doesn't say
which one it is more than this no one
else it's okay stay with me people stay
with okay let's just stop it okay hop I
swear Simon right half R squared x
squared 10 divide everything through
okay so now let's replay it again
okay the textbook begins and it says
there is a circle and you're like what
does this have to do with calculus again
okay they like just wait I'll get there
eventually it didn't like in like two
hours okay
hahaha there you go they prove this
inequality then they use this inequality
to prove this limit right and then they
use this limit so they can simplify
first principles for limit as X
approaches H approaches zero of you know
for the one and there that long last we
get to the derivative of sine being
caused and then you get everything else
from that which we already saw yesterday
okay
exhale that was it okay like I said like
I said this proof
okay I'm not showing you this proof
because you must reproduce it like
Section E or actually it's not
sectioning anymore that question for or
something like that it's just prove the
derivative sign X from my first first
really super first principles okay
they're never gonna ask you to prove
that however you think about what well
this is their words I'm this is really
emitter okay then you've got limits then
you've got trade expansions they're your
limits again all of that stuff you do
need to know okay so all the pieces of
this you must understand one more thing
and this is actually important when you
are are thinking about where all of this
came from okay
this meant maybe it seems normal to you
but didn't amend when your differ any
differentiating trig functions
everything must be in radians okay now
I'd actually like you get a red pin out
okay I know what you're by this because
this is crucial
okay is it gonna come back and bite you
everything to do in trig and calculus
differentiating later well we're gonna
learn integration as well whatever that
means
okay all that must be in radians now
that seems weird cuz you're like radians
degrees it's just a measurement thing
right just units like if I said to you
ah tell me how tall I am in centimeters
well what can my BMI are you don't send
me then you send me this we use meters
whatever be that's no problem I can use
whichever units I want right now
the reason I can't use whatever units I
want is because this whole result
particularly this part and this part but
you know make sense if you do them in
degrees
these are reading measure designs right
if you plug in degrees here things are
going to break down actually it's mostly
this one right so when you're coming
back to differentiated and I'm gonna do
it all in radians and I'm doing
integration and only doing it in radians
you're like why is that it's because
where it all started was writing measure
okay does that make sense it's going to
come back and be very important so just
keep that